i always want to evolve and grow and
mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people khloe kardashian
loves her body stretch marks and all
it's my lifestyle
the 36 year old mama hit up instagram
over the weekend to show off her curves
in a black
two-piece swimsuit yeah that's coco
showing off her booty and waist
looking freaking fire the caption
i love my stripes oh my gosh
the good american founders big sis kim
tossed some praise at chloe writing
it's the waste for me to which chloe
responded quote
kim kardashian you taught me all the
angles
you haven't know your angle you have to
know you know the lighting is everything
but chloe isn't the first member of the
kardashian family to proudly flaunt her
stretch marks
courtney who has three kids of her own
has shared several shots in the past
choosing not to edit out her stretch
marks like
this 2019 bikini pick which she
captioned quote
stretch marks we've all got them and
when court shared
this unedited snap on pusha's account
that same year
fans flooded the comment section to
praise her for keeping it real
and when one user thanked her for not
editing out her stretch marks
she responded quote i love my little
stripes
courtney is badass one thing's for sure
coco has that body positive thing
on lock back in 2017 chloe opened up to
et
about her 40 pound weight loss and
offered her tips to getting in shape
i was always chubby and i always just
you kind of just own it like no i'm just
big boned and this is just who i
am but i needed a stress reliever and i
turned to that instead of i always
emotionally ate so for once i was like
well the pints of ice cream never worked
for me so let me try this elliptical
and the clarity that i got after working
out i felt so great and then as a
byproduct i started losing weight
and she showed off the fruits of her
labor on that kardashian jenner girls
trip
chloe courtney kim kendall and kylie
all posted up in their itty bitty teeny
tiny bikinis
during the family getaway to turks and
caicos
i don't believe that a weight defines
you
i don't weigh myself because i don't
care at all what number i am
i think to be happy that comes from
within there's so many miserable people
that are thin
and they're hungry